please welcome the tireless the
brilliant deborah norville
thank you hi ross hello i walk past your
studio every day it's so nice to have
the door open and to see people in here
this is incredible
ross is here my intrepid co-pilot
who helps us with the headlines every
day and so much more
ross matthew thank you thank you hi but
it is about deborah norville i
love you so much i was so excited to
hear you were here i mean i knew you
were here because i see the show
but we last saw each other at one of the
awards shows and i don't remember which
one it was the golden globes i remember
i thought you would never remember no
but yeah
absolutely yeah so it's nice to see you
again and congratulations to you too
well congratulations
25 years i know you have to say like 25
years
exactly like the count i have to say
that i'm
i've been looking through all of your
books um
and this one i was reading late last
night
these short stories of the way that
people
find gratitude and i know gratitude is
such a big thing for you can you also
teach us about something i've learned
from you which is the gratitude list i'd
like to
start and try this but can i thank you
yes ask the founder of this idea how to
attack it i'm hardly the founder but
what i think i
am is the person who did the research
and took all the peer-reviewed stuff
and made it so that normal people like
us could understand it and so
the gist of of what got me hooked on
gratitude was
i'd always heard that if you see it you
can be it well i see myself 10 pounds
lighter but if i don't do something
it won't happen and i think gratitude is
the same way and in fact
i practiced it on my five-year-old my
fifth grade son at the time
and he hated school i said well
didn't anything good happen no nothing
could happen who did you sit by at lunch
and he would say
so and so what'd y'all talk about oh he
invited me for a playdate one good thing
long story short at the end of the day
he would say mom i've got my three good
things
i knew that he would like school more
what i didn't know was that his grades
would improve
wow and so there's actually research
that shows
children who have in their mind a moment
that makes them so happy they just want
to dance and you've got little girls and
it's hard right now they're studying and
it's remote and nothing's normal
but but little children who have a
wiggly happy moment
before they go and take a test retain
the information that they had learned
and regurgitate it back successfully on
the test so i actually told my kids
before they had their sats
you think of a wiggly happy moment
whatever it is if it works for you
and so there is power and gratitude in
so many different ways so i'm so glad
you're into it i want to read something
that you wrote
studies that show people who hear
stories of good deeds report
literally feeling a sense of warmth in
their chest
and a desire to replicate it in their
own way
the kinds of deeds they've just heard
about i mean that to me i was like
that's the motto of drew's news that's
the mission we're here that's pay it
forward
[Music]
you